welcome to this video Brian Wood is the
opponent in that 25-minute game and he's
not very high rated in there in the
other pools so let's see what we get
here Kings Indian or grew throughout
this is this is the main choice so Kings
Indian what about something else I can
do this maybe the night and the bishop d
392 variation that's something that yeah
so Sarah one has played a lot it's an
interesting line let's see how he plays
against it one idea is to just still
keep that option open of playing a three
like in the sameish but you put more
emphasis on quick development of them on
the Kings side ok let's go f3 in order
to prepare Bishop e3 we that looks a lot
like as a mesh sameish Kings onion
that might be a direct transposition to
some line of this image interesting um
anyway I like my position I've got more
space and he's not really quick with
getting any great counter plain night
age five in order to go f5 that's one
way to try to get counter play or start
with the move like b5 these kind of
setups are not that bad actually when
Garry Kasparov was still active he
played this way against the sameish
quite often with the g5 and he had
pretty good success with it even though
it never was very popular but but he
scored well that showed that sometimes
unpopular lines just need the right
player to to get to show that they're
not that bad really we should to be
several s been puzzling a well yes
played be five but while the bishop is
not really great down on b7 okay i think
i will take with the Queen it's not so
clear what to do but i think that's not
a bad move the bishop is just I mean
he's not having the bishop on b7 is not
helping on the Kings side is what I'm
trying to say and
on the queenside I'm much much better
anyway so putting it there doesn't
really help yeah so let's have a look
yeah i wonder if i should go night a
form simply forcing trait of the quay em
wow I'm kind of twisting might wrong
here a little bit forcing the Queen
trade so what I'm trying to say light
takes a form I can also just take with
the rook on a phone it's not a bad idea
anyway my original intention was Knight
takes a for Queen da droopy a Droog a
form and then just puts put more
pressure on the apron it's a bit
puzzling that he's not taking on a for
quicker because yeah there wasn't any
other move anyway so let's let's do this
I have the a pawn to a check and I think
that's all I need my pieces here the
bishop on d3 and the night only tool
they very nicely cover all the entries
squares on the sea fowl so if he goes
rook c8 which looks very normal then
rook a one is just piling up on that
pawn and it's not so clear if he has
anything anything good it cannot enter
anywhere a good idea for black would be
to somehow try to activate his bishop
like via f6 f6d 8b 6 that would be nice
but it also takes quite a bit of time
well it really doesn't have half that
time I guess but I think he has to try I
don't see a way to keep that porn
protected ok ok you can play some rather
sad move like night b8 to cover that
porn but that's really not how you want
to play chess
now it all comes down to that bad Bishop
Andhra sound that's not doing anything
you have an interesting an interesting
moment here actually I'm not sure how to
play here I can go look a one as I
planned but there also is the idea of
playing just look see one okay and
they'll think it's a good idea it just
this point is just lost or as mentioned
that awkward night b8 move after which i
can play be five by the way it's it's a
possibility yeah it's not just a
possibility its strong that winds up on
anyway
no it's just it's just gone the point is
gone
okay he gives he he gives away the pawn
like that the point one point might be
if i take were the pawnees 95 which
doesn't help him ready mmm yeah i will
take with a rock I have Roo k7 as a
major threat okay well that's that just
catches to winning end game so let's not
be sophisticated TMP should be five is
good right yeah a text that night if it
goes to f6 I go Bishop c6 and after the
trade my pawns will promote night be a
this Bishop e7 loses the night yeah okay
that's that's a well he has no no real
defensive
black resigns yeah so yeah as I said
lots of mismatches in the first stages
of first stage of that new pool let's
have a look there I think it looks som
that looks som that looks quite quite
good for white but it's a it's a fairly
normal position I like it but it's not
not bad for black or anything not sure
about b5 that whole thing there are
ideas like that in this opening but i'm
not sure if it is some applying here
before and then a for coming I really
don't like it what can I say the engine
also likes right quite a bit yeah our
Bishop e7 is wrong it's just wrong maybe
this is a way to defend better like
let's say here now it still doesn't feel
right the Queen side is quite weak yeah
here that's already a very bad position
that the a pawn is very weak I think yes
so maybe try something like that just to
get activity just trying to do something
but play Knight b6 and after that I
don't think I don't think you can I
would it the a porn is essentially gone
I don't know there's no way to really
hold it it's routine one yeah at a five
did hell but he has no moves check and
TI bishops is six world east side yeah
that was um too bad an opening to him to
UM to put up to put up a fight not sure
I mean this is kind of as I said a
playable set up but I'd I'm not sure
about b5 ready in some cases you can do
that but I think this is more of a
we're black should try to get f5 going
an interesting idea is this thing this
is a motif it's pretty nice for wide
usually and important to know but I've
didn't happen in the game okay well
thanks for watching